We just got the first awesome trailer for
Black Panther which gives us a glorious peek
inside the world of Wakanda and a first look
at new villains in the MCU.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, it's Jan here
and in this video, I'm breaking down the Black
Panther trailer for easter eggs, references
and other teases for what we can look forward
to seeing in the movie.
The trailer kicks off with the return of Ulysses
Klaue and he's missing his left arm which
you'll probably remember he lost when Ultron
cut it off in Avengers: Age of Ultron.
Klaue was stockpiling vibranium which he sold
to Ultron in that movie and here he's being
interrogated by Everett Ross, the CIA op who
appeared for the first time in Captain America:
Civil War.
In the comics, Klaue also loses a limb and
gets a prosthetic arm equipped with a sonic
emitter that he uses as a weapon, and I'll
talk more about that later.
By the way, I'm sure it won't be lost on fans
of The Hobbit that, thanks to this scene,
we're seeing Bilbo Baggins and Gollum together
again!
Next up is this misty shot of an enormous
waterfall which reminded me of the last time
we saw Black Panther in the mid-credits scene
for Captain America: Civil War when T'Challa
and Steve Rogers looked out over a jungle
landscape with a waterfall in the distance.
This is actually Warrior Falls and in the
following shots we'll see T'Challa emerging
from his Royal Talon Fighter for his coronation
ceremony.
You no doubt noticed T'Challa's fantastic
tattoos as he steps out of his craft and it's
a little difficult to see here, but they're
actually panther-themed.
And greeting T'Challa for the ceremony is
Forest Whitaker who is playing Zuri, a spiritual
leader and a father-like figure to T'Challa.
Director Ryan Coogler has described Zuri as
an Obi-Wan Kenobi-type character who will
advise and guide Black Panther in the movie.
And with Zuri you can also see these children
preparing for the ceremonial ritual.
They're using something called the Heart-Shaped
Herb.
In the comics, the juices of this herb are
prepared in a ceremony and given only to those
who are worthy enough to become the Black
Panther.
The herb gives the receiver super-strength,
speed, agility, senses and healing powers
which you can see in some of the awesome action
shots in the trailer.
Notice, for example, the force with which
T'Challa slams this guy into a truck and the
incredible back-flips in this shot.
And the way Black Panther's vibranium armour
just deflects these bullets reminds me of
that rooftop scene in Civil War where bullets
also just glanced off him.
Also in the trailer we get one of our new
villains: Erik Killmonger, who's actually
the guy behind the mask breaking Klaue out
from his detention with a team of mercs.
Killmonger is a supervillain and a powerful
nemesis of Black Panther, and the mask he's
wearing here is a bit different from the one
he has in the comics, though it retains the
mane around the mask.
Erik Killmonger is played by Michael B. Jordan
who worked with Black Panther director Ryan
Coogler previously on Creed and Fruitvale
Station, and we can see Killmonger apprehended
later in the trailer and escorted by W'Kabi
who is T'Challa's chief of security in the
comics.
W'Kabi is played by Daniel Kaluuya who recently
starred in the horror movie Get Out.
And it looks like Killmonger has been escorted
to meet T'Challa and the other tribal leaders
in this throne room.
By the way, this tribal leader with a lip
plate is currently described on IMDB as a
River Tribe Elder.
There's a number of T'Challa's elite female
bodyguards, the Dora Milaje, in the trailer.
Overseeing the interrogation of Klaue is Okoye,
played by Danai Gurira from The Walking Dead.
And there's this very cool group shot of the
Dora Milaje headed up by Florence Kasumba.
Kasumba appeared briefly in Captain America:
Civil War where she faced off with Black Widow,
telling the Avenger to move or be moved.
Back to this trailer, in the casino scene
is Nakia, played by Lupita Nyong'o and she
also appears later in her Dora Milaje outfit
with some cool disc-like weapons.
And next to Nakia is Shuri, T'Challa's sister,
played by Letitia Wright, and she's sporting
some very cool Panther-style blasters.
These are likely a vibranium-based weapon
that she's developed herself, because her
background in the movie is that she's spent
many years researching vibranium and developing
technology.
Which makes me wonder if Klaue will be trying
to steal some of her tech for his weaponised
prosthetic arm?
Nakia and Shuri also show up again in this
scene with T'Challa's mother Ramonda.
This shot is set in the mountain terrain of
the Jabari tribe and another scene introduces
their leader M'Baku, also known in the comics
as Man-Ape.
M'Baku is a powerful tribal leader who's been
a long-standing enemy of Black Panther in
the comics.
His comic book character led the outlawed
White Gorilla cult and he obtained super-strength
after taking part in a ritual involving a
white gorilla.
And you can see a little nod to that perhaps
in the white fur he and his followers are
wearing.
Now, this is an interesting shot, because
look carefully at the spokes on Black Panther's
collar and they're definitely different to
the ones we saw him wear in Captain America:
Civil War and earlier in the trailer.
I'm curious as to whether this is a flashback,
an early version of his suit or perhaps his
suit's been damaged and he's had to go back
to an earlier prototype.
So, what did you think of the Black Panther
trailer and did it get you hyped up for the
movie?
And were there any other easter eggs or cool
details you noticed?
I'd love to hear your thoughts in the comments
below.
If you enjoyed this, you might also like my
Wonder Woman easter eggs video where I've
got a cool giveaway for an awesome art of
the movie book.
And don't forget to give this video a thumbs-up
if you liked it and while you're here check
out some of my other videos by tapping or
clicking the screen.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time!
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!